When you work for the SCP Foundation, one
certainty is that nothing – no turn of events,
no scenario – is ever really unexpected.
No matter how unlikely something may appear,
chances are it usually happens.
And if it doesn’t happen here, then in an
infinite multiverse of alternatives, everything
than can possibly happen is statistically
likely to.
We’ve covered a few of these alternate eventualities
before, a number of which revolve around the
differing events in the long life of one particular
anomaly: SCP-076-2, better known as Able.
In our own home universe, much like he is
in many others, Able is considered to be a
near-perfect warrior.
His body, covered in tattoos of occult symbols
and demonic faces, is capable of withstanding
vast amounts of physical damage.
Able can easily take hits from the most powerful
conventional weapons mankind has to offer,
and survive with little more than a scratch.
What’s more, he can draw an endless supply
of black-bladed weapons from a tiny pocket
dimension.
And on top of all that, even in the event
that he’s bested in combat, Able’s body
will rapidly disintegrate, only to reform
within a large stone cube known as SCP-076-1.
Like most of us, Able has a number of almost
identical counterparts that exist across the
various worlds of the multiverse.
One of them once had the opportunity to reconcile
with his brother Cain, the man seemingly responsible
for Able’s endless life of bloodshed.
And once the two brothers had made peace,
they could rest.
In another universe, Able worked directly
with the SCP Foundation as part of a Mobile
Task Force, until they turned on him.
This unfurled a chain of events so cataclysmic
that the entire world would suffer the consequences.
This alternate Able went on the warpath against
the Foundation, ultimately using SCP-914,
the Clockworks, to refine his destructive
anomalous abilities.
This allowed him to unleash chaos, slaughtering
all of humanity in an omnicide that wiped
the world clean of all other life, leaving
Able sat alone in a dead world.
And then there was this version of the immortal
warrior.
Far from the Clockworks enhanced conqueror
that his alternate universe counterpart was,
this Able had long since been removed as a
member of MTF Omega 7, and was gradually reconstituting
his body within SCP-076-1.
His most recent defeat had enraged the warrior,
and he had vowed to once again be free.
Although, unbeknownst to him, what set this
particular version of Able apart from his
other variants was the fact that he would
soon encounter a certain other anomaly.
Something that, when wielded by SCP-076-2
had the potential to… completely rob him
of all his centuries’ worth of fighting
ability and replace it with an embarrassment
that would last for centuries more.
But first, a quick history lesson.
Much like it had been in our universe, this
particular anomalous object had been recovered
by the Foundation after it made its way into
the hands of an unwitting police officer.
The item in question was SCP-572, a particularly
unique katana.
Unique in that it was utterly useless for
fighting with, and caused more harm to the
person wielding it than whoever they were
trying to use it against.
In this universe, the sword had already changed
hands a number of times.
When police were called to the home of one
Clarence ‘Clancy’ Clancerson, he drew
SCP-572 in defense and screamed at the officers
that he would “take their heads, and with
it, their power.”
The cops, who had been sent over to arrest
Clancy for violent and disorderly behavior,
were less than threatened to see their suspect
– who was somewhat out of shape – coming
at them with a weapon no sharper than a butter
knife.
After pacifying Clancy with tasers and beanbag
rounds from a twelve gauge shotgun, the police
retrieved SCP-572, and it was then acquired
by a Foundation operative.
This all played out almost the exact same
way in our universe.
However, in this version of events, there
was one key difference.
As previously mentioned, SCP-572 was an unremarkable
sword, but it had something of a storied past,
passing from one unfortunate user to the next.
And just as it has recovered from Clancy’s
house and ended up in Foundation hands, one
of those former owners had just been about
to reclaim the fabled weapon for himself…
Meanwhile, back in this containment chamber,
deep under the ocean, still trapped in the
stone cube he reanimated within, Able was
lost in a dream.
To any other person, falling asleep to see
subconscious visions of so much carnage would
be horrifying; they’d call it a nightmare.
But to Able, this might have been one of the
sweetest dreams he had ever experienced.
All around him was a world on fire, having
returned to life once again, Able had at last
bested his captors at the SCP Foundation.
In his dream, he had traveled the world, visiting
every Foundation facility one by one and reducing
them to rubble, without leaving a single survivor.
Then, once the work was done, he turned his
barbarism towards the wider world, and began
slaughtering humanity in droves.
Perhaps some distant cosmic echo had reached
out across the multiverse, a fragment of the
life of a more refined version of himself
had slipped into Able’s subconscious, making
him dream that he, too, was the omnicidal
conqueror that his other self was.
Seeing such devastation in his own wake made
this version of Able eager to wake up, to
revive once more and set about making this
delightful dream of destruction a deadly reality.
It was while Able was dreaming, picturing
himself cutting down all who dared to oppose
him, that something strange seemed to happen.
He had a visitor.
Not a visitor to his containment chamber,
mind you.
There was no one beyond the confines of SCP-076-1
except the security team that normally kept
the stone cube under armed surveillance.
No, this visitor appeared somewhere else:
inside Able’s mind, approaching him as he
slept.
Within the warrior’s slumbering fantasy,
he was climbing up a mountain of skulls after
having slaughtered millions – if not billions
– already.
But as he reached the top of the pile of bones,
and looked out over the horizon, Able could
see that the world beyond was still living.
There were just as many people alive, perhaps
even more than he’d already killed.
His work was not yet done – in fact, it
seemed that despite all the lives the immortal
madman had already claimed, he had barely
even begun.
“Oh, Able,” a voice tutted.
“Did you really think you could do it alone?”
Even though this was a dream, Able could feel
the presence of another.
He pulled one of his obsidian-edged weapons
from thin air and swiped in the direction
the voice had come from, hitting nothing.
The blade in his hand seemed to change, its
dark metal transforming from solid to liquid.
Coming apart in his hands, Able’s sword
melted like candle wax under a hot flame,
reduced to nothing in seconds.
“You can’t do it,” the voice whispered.
“You aren’t strong enough.
But I can help with that.”
Pulling home another weapon, a two-handed
axe this time, Able looked around him, trying
to locate the source of the taunting noise.
“Only a coward relies on cheap tricks and
illusions!” he growled angrily.
“Show yourself!
Come forward and be slain!
Are you a worthy opponent?
Are you worth your time?”
“Are you?”
the voice jested.
“We shall see!”
Able yelled.
Behind him, a cloaked figure silently appeared.
They looked to be adorned in a robe that whipped
in the biting cold wind, yet their garments
weren’t made of any fabric.
Instead, they wore a robe made out of pure
shadow, their clothes and body comprised of
the same thing.
Though they lacked any tangible, solid matter,
it didn’t stop Able from spinning around,
swinging his heavy axe in the figure’s direction.
Before the blade of the weapon was even halfway
through the air, it had already started to
become liquid – just like the swords had
earlier.
By the time it came down to strike at the
shadowy visitor, what had once been an axe
was just a flick of melted black metal, passing
through the intangible specter as Able found
himself once again unarmed.
“Speak, cretin!” he demanded, never one
to back away from a fight, even when his weapons
were seemingly failing him.
“Tell me who you are.
I would know my adversary’s name before
I end your worthless life.”
“I’m not here to fight you,” the figure
replied calmly.
“I’m here to offer you the key to your
victory, Able.”
“What key?”
the warrior sneered.
“What could you possibly give me?”
“Exactly what you need to finish it,”
the shadow replied, drawing something from
a sheath on its belt and holding it aloft.
“A weapon that will allow you to become
the conqueror you long to be.”
Able looked at the object in the figure’s
outstretched hand: a katana.
Or at least, the shadowy vestige of one.
“A sword?” he sneered.
“What use do I have for a sword?
I can conjure all the blades I need at will!”
To demonstrate, Able pulled one of his own
black blades, but yet again it began to melt
away.
“Your weapons have served you well, but
they are disposable,” the shadow explained.
“A true warrior deserves a sword worthy
of his fighting prowess.”
“I have killed scores of men through the
ages,” the immortal warrior retorted.
“And I never needed any special sword to
do that!”
“And that is why, no matter how many you
kill, you will always be beaten.”
In his dream, Able paused a moment, looking
at the katana and considering.
Then, he reached his hand out to grip the
shadowy hilt.
In that same split second, SCP-076-2 awoke
once again from his slumber and broke free
of the stone cube encasing him.
As he killed his way through the Foundation
personnel in the facility housing SCP-076-1,
Able had only one thought in his mind: he
needed that sword.
You see, what the immortal maniac was unfortunately
totally unaware of, was the interesting effect
SCP-572 could have on people.
As well as being a totally useless sword,
anyone who picked it up will instantly believe
the Katana of Apparent Invincibility to be
an all powerful weapon of ancient legend.
Despite the sword being crudely made, blunt
and generally unfit for any use, the wielder
will maintain the belief that it not only
has perfect balance and cutting power, but
that the sword has also imbued them with unparalleled
strength and invincibility to damage.
And now, either through the sword itself extending
this cognitohazardous influence into Able’s
dream, or by the interference of some unknown
trickery, one of the most dangerous anomalous
killers in the world was making a beeline
straight for SCP-572… and he wasn’t the
only one either.
At a previous point in time, a man by the
name of Zac had purchased SCP-572 on ebay.
But it was far more than just an oddity to
him, he wasn’t looking to start a sword
collection.
As a child, he had been obsessed with comic
book superheroes, and when Zac bought that
katana, he intended to use the blade to dispense
vigilante justice against those who preyed
on the innocent.
And even before he held it in his hands, Zac
too had felt the anomalous pull of the katana,
knowing in his heart it was the perfect weapon
to transform him into a hero.
Of course, he had quickly been disproven when,
on his first night of crimefighting, Zac had
been hit by a mid size sedan in a multi storey
parking lot and suffered a concussion.
Sent to the hospital and then charged with
attempted assault, Zac had long since lost
any and all interest in ever donning his costume
– comprised of hockey pads and a ski mask
– or picking up the sword ever again.
But as time had gone on, that old familiar
pull had started to gnaw at Zac, urging him
to get back in the superhero game; forgetting
how poorly that had worked out for him last
time.
One problem still stood in his way though:
he needed his trusty sword back.
Of course, in the time since he’d hung up
his hero outfit, Clancy had gotten his hands
on SCP-572.
And then, right before Zac could steal it
back, the Foundation had taken it.
It had taken him months of preparation.
He’d sneakily made dealings with a janitor
that worked at one of the Foundation sites.
Zac had bribed the man a lot of money in exchange
for his key card and uniform, even having
to take out a second mortgage on his apartment
to meet the frankly extortionate amount the
janitor asked for.
But it would be worth the cost, Zac told himself;
if it reunited him with his trusty katana
then it’d be worth it.
Only then would he once again be a full hero.
Shuffling through the facility, Zac dragged
a mop over the floor, leaving a sign to warn
of the slippery hazard.
He whistled to himself, trying to act as casually
as possible, not realizing that he was slightly
overselling it.
Once he was certain the coast was clear, he
made his move.
SCP-572 was locked in a secure deposit box
within Site 19’s High-Value Item Storage
Facility, right where he had been cleaning.
He began searching through the various anomalous
oddities kept there, until he saw it: the
box containing his coveted sword.
All his effort in infiltrating the Foundation
had finally paid off, it was all leading to
this, his comeback to crimefighting…
It was at this precise moment that Able came
bursting through a nearby door.
Completely befuddled, Zac quickly found himself
thrown to one side by the much stronger man.
“Out of my way, weakling!”
Able roared, before turning to face the deposit
box holding SCP-572.
Gripping the box, Able used his superhuman
strength to tear it open as though the container
was made from carboard.
There it was: stored safely within was the
weapon he had been seeking, the same all-powerful
sword from his vision.
“At last,” he declared, reaching for the
hilt.
“The sword belongs to me!”
The second that Able hoisted it into the air,
he felt a human weight dash towards him, only
to shrug it off as it made impact.
Zac tumbled to the floor, winded as Able barely
flinched at the attempted tackle.
“You fool!” he roared.
“You dare come at me?
You’ll be the first to fall to my new blade,
the first of this pathetic world of unworthy
opponents to die in my conquest.”
Zac frightenedly raised his arms in an attempt
to shield himself, while Able raised the sword
menacingly above his head.
The mortal man knew what that sword was capable
of… or so he thought.
As Able brought the blade swiping downwards,
its true ineffectiveness as a melee weapon
was on full display.
SCP-572’s dull, poorly balanced blade barely
grazed Zac’s arms as he protected his face,
in fact, beyond the initial swat, it barely
hurt.
“I-I don’t understand,” Able stammered,
looking at the katana in confusion.
“This is meant to be a warrior’s blade,
a weapon of champions and conquerors.”
“Yeah, that’s what I was thinking,”
Zac replied, also suffering from SCP-572’s
congntio hazardous effect – he’d fully
expected to die a second ago, slain by the
very weapon he had been hoping to reclaim.
“Still, maybe it’s just because it’s
your first go?
I could show you how to-”
“Silence, I won't fall for that!”
Able interrupted.
“Let me see here, maybe the angle was off?
Or how about I use both hands, here let me
just…”
Once again, Able hoisted the weapon, this
time with both hands tightly gripping the
blade, intending to bring it slashing down
in a big swing like a woodsman cleaving a
log in two.
Unfortunately, as he raised the sword, the
blade caught an exposed light fixture above.
Sparks burst from the ceiling as an electrical
current shot through the metal, and gave Able
a nasty shock.
“Ouch!
What is the meaning of this?” he shouted
in frustration.
“I’ve been alive for centuries, killed
thousands upon thousands of men since the
dawn civilization.
Why can’t I use this sword?!”
“Well, performance issues in a guy your
age, hardly an uncommon problem,” Zac joked.
Both turned at the sound of a door being kicked
open, the clomp of heavy boots on the ground
as a Foundation security team burst in.
“SCP-076-2, drop your weapons and-” the
commander stopped mid-shout.
“Wait, that’s not one of his regular swords,
is it?”
“Sir, that’s…” one of the officers
paused and sighed.
“I think that’s SCP-572.”
“Attack me!”
Able yelled at the Foundation officers, pointing
the dull tip of the katana at them.
“If you dare!
For I now wield the greatest blade known to
the universe!
You will all fall in a single stroke of my
new weapon.
And once you have fallen, so shall the world!”
“SCP-076-2 – Able, look – just put that
thing down,” the commander urged.
“Trust me, you’ll thank yourself.”
“Pah, you pathetic fools are so afraid of
the chaos I will unleash!”
the warrior declared.
“Such unworthy opponents!”
“Okay, I’ve seen enough,” the security
commander sighed.
“Deadly force authorized.
Light him up, boys.”
On the commander’s signal, a hail of gunfire
erupted, bullets raining down on Able.
He slashed SCP-572 through the air, certain
that what he thought was a mighty sword could
easily cut through the oncoming bullets.
Of course, that may have been true, if SCP-572’s
only real power was not having any power at
all.
Each shot struck Able center mass, barely
damaging him given his body’s natural resilience
to harm, particularly from such small arms
fire.
Although, he didn’t find it any less annoying
that he couldn’t seem to properly wield
his new katana.
“Oh, are you kidding me?” he huffed to
himself.
“What is with me today?
Can’t get the hang of this thing; come on,
Able, it’s still a sword.
The weapon that will allow me to conquer this
whole world, but if I can just get the swing
right…”
Calmly, knowing that the weapon itself posed
no threat – even in the hands of an immortal
mass murderer – the security team moved
in to apprehend Able.
Before they could take the katana from his
hands, he dashed towards them, swiping the
sword back and forth, hoping to hit at least
someone to get the ball rolling on his omnicidal
rampage.
Instead, thanks to the influence of SCP-572,
he miscalculated, took a wrong step, and slipped
over on a patch of freshly-mopped tile, landing
in a heap next to a ‘Wet Floor’ sign.
The security team all winced, feeling the
secondhand embarrassment practically radiating
off Able as the ancient anomalous warrior
lay on the floor after a spectacular fall.
Then, one by one, they all burst out into
uncontrollable fits of laughter.
But while they were distracted, they were
completely oblivious to Zac, who emerged from
his hiding place and picked SCP-572 up off
the floor.
He breathed a sigh of relief, reunited with
his prized weapon; having forgotten the severe
injury it caused him last time.
“You…”
Able wheezed, still lying in a puddle of mop
water.
“Who are you?”
Zac gave a slight smile, unzipping the janitor’s
overalls he had on to reveal a set of hockey
pads underneath.
He slipped a ski mask over his face before
turning back to able and replying, in his
most epic voice:
“I’m Captain Katana.”
Unfortunately, his return to crime fighting
would be as short-lived as Able’s own turn
with SCP-572.
As Captain Katana found himself hit by a bus
on his way home after trying to use the Katana
of Apparent Invincibility to cut said bus
in half down the middle… and failing in
a rather painful fashion.
Want an anomaly of your own?
Check out www.scpswag.com for high-quality
SCP merch!
Now go and check out “IS SCP-572 THE MOST
DANGEROUS WEAPON EVER?” and “SCP-076 ABLE
VS CHAINSAW MAN...
WHO HAS THE MOST LETHAL WEAPON?”
to get your weapon fanatic fix!